Summer blockbuster season is here, and new
trailers are being released nearly every day.
It's hard to keep up with the constant influx
of epic footage, so we've compiled a handy
list—here's a rundown of all the trailers
released in May that will absolutely blow
you away this summer... and beyond...
Okja
Snowpiercer director Bong Joon Ho partnered
with Netflix for Okja, a movie with an all-star
cast and a deep message about environmental
protection.
The studio finally released a full trailer
earlier this month, showing off the movie's
gorgeous visuals and its absolutely bizarre
plot: a young girl attempting to rescue her
pet super-pig named Okja before an evil corporation
can turn it into food.
Jake Gyllenhaal, Paul Dano, Tilda Swinton,
and Giancarlo Esposito also show up in the
trailer, which promises a unique thrill ride
from start to finish.
Check it out on June 28.
The House
Starring Will Ferrell and Amy Poehler as two
parents who open up an underground casino
to fill up their daughter's college fund,
The House makes an early bid for the summer's
raunchiest comedy.
And if the film's Red Band trailer is any
indication, their quick-money scheme doesn't
go as smoothly as they hoped.
Look for all the high-octane hijinks on June
30.
Spider-Man: Homecoming
The final trailer for Spider-Man: Homecoming
really sets this reboot apart from the previous
Spidey films.
We get more glimpses of the cool tech that
Tony Stark built into Peter's suit, including
his own version of JARVIS.
"You have 576 possible web-shooter combinations."
Like past trailers, this footage highlights
how much Tony wants Peter to quit crimefighting,
but it also offers some fun glimpses of Tony
as a mentor.
This dynamic will prove crucial once Spidey
gets started—Michael Keaton's Vulture is
a terrifying villain for young Parker to start
off against, so he'll probably need a lot
of help from Iron Man.
Finally, it gives us our best look yet at
Donald Glover's mysterious character.
Swing in to see it on July 7.
War For the Planet of the Apes
The final trailer for War for the Planet of
the Apes proves the movie isn't pulling any
punches in the escalating war between man
and ape.
There's a heavy emphasis on the differences
between Andy Serkis' Caesar and Woody Harrelson's
ruthless Colonel, setting up the humans as
savages, rather than the apes.
The trailer also also features a heavy dose
of Steve Zahn's Bad Ape, a new character who
seems destined to become a fan favorite.
The trailer promises no mercy and no peace—and
an epic, violent showdown to take the franchise
to the next level on July 14.
The Big Sick
This isn't your typical rom-com.
The Big Sick stars Silicon Valley's Kumail
Nanjiani, who co-wrote the script alongside
his wife, Emily V. Gordon, based on the true
story of how they met and fell in love.
But their biggest problem is one most couples
never have to experience: shortly into their
courtship, Emily falls into a coma.
It's a rollercoaster of emotions, and the
movie's early reviews suggest Nanjiani and
Gordon hit them in all the right places.
The Big Sick has a June 23rd release date
Dunkirk
Christopher Nolan is a master of suspense,
and he's proved it again with the second trailer
for his upcoming war thriller Dunkirk, starring
Tom Hardy, Cillian Murphy, Kenneth Branagh,
and former One Direction singer Harry Styles
in the story of the 1940 evacuation of the
French city of Dunkirk, where thousands of
soldiers were left stranded on a beach surrounded
by enemy forces.
The trailer definitely gets viewers' pulses
pounding, successfully ramping up anticipation
for an intense, fast-paced experience unlike
any war film you've seen before.
Check it out July 21st.
Valerian
The final trailer for the upcoming sci-fi
thriller Valerian and the City of a Thousand
Planets doesn't give away much of the plot,
instead focusing on the film's incredible
visuals, teasing a feast for the eyes when
the movie hits the big screen on July 21.
Valerian won't just be all visual thrills,
though.
Based on a French graphic novel—which also
heavily influenced the visuals of director
Luc Besson's The Fifth Element—Valerian
tells a hell of a story, following two time-traveling
agents tasked with saving the planet Alpha
from a mysterious, all-consuming threat.
Clive Owen, John Goodman, Ethan Hawke, and
Rihanna also pop up in the project, which
promises to be another hit sci-fi action film
for the Fifth Element director.
The Dark Tower
Inspired by Stephen King's bestselling saga
of the same name, this adaptation's been many,
many years in the making, but the first trailer
suggests that time might have been just what
filmmakers needed to get the story right.
The trailer is almost all action from start
to finish, starting with an intense dream
experienced by young Jake Chambers—one which
foreshadows a journey into a visually stunning
world grounded by impressive performances
by Idris Elba and Matthew McConaughey.
The Dark Tower's trailer doesn't give much
away—instead offering just enough to leave
viewers champing at the bit for the film's
release on August 4.
Wind River
Avengers stars Jeremy Renner and Elizabeth
Olsen play very different kinds of heroes
in the upcoming thriller Wind River when they're
tasked with hunting down a killer in the icy
wilderness of the Wind River Indian Reservation.
We're ready for a thrilling, intense ride
when Wind River arrives on August 4.
Good Time
From A24, the indie studio behind Get Out,
Good Time stars Robert Pattinson as Connie,
a man on a mission to get his mentally handicapped
brother Nick out of jail after their attempted
bank robbery goes awry.
Pattinson is electric in the trailer, and
early reviews are calling this his best performance
yet in what looks to be one of the most intense—and
beautiful—thrillers released in recent years.
Good Time hits studios August 11.
The Hitman's Bodyguard
The first trailer for The Hitman's Bodyguard
gave us a lot of action and swearing, but
the newest preview goes deeper into the film's
story and gives us a glimpse of Gary Oldman
as the ruthless villain.
It also teases more of the bickering partnership
between Ryan Reynolds' and Samuel L. Jackson's
characters.
"27 times.
That's how many times he tried to kill me
28!"
Putting these two together promises the potential
for one of the summer's most explosive comedies.
Look for it August 18.
Logan Lucky
Helmed by acclaimed writer-director Steven
Soderbergh, Logan Lucky is an action-comedy
starring Channing Tatum and Adam Driver as
brothers who decide to rob the Coca-Cola 600,
one of the biggest races of the year...with
the help of inmate Joe Bang, played with gusto
by Daniel Craig.
"I am in-car-cer-ate-ed."
This fun, '80s-inspired trailer uses bright
images, an upbeat score, and a lot of one-liners
to convince viewers to race out to the theater
on August 18.
It Stains the Sand Red
Horror thriller It Stains the Sand Red follows
a woman stuck in the desert pursued by an
untiring member of the undead, and the trailer
promises a picture that flips the genre on
its head and make tired tropes actually scary
again.
Leave the lights on when you check out the
trailer, and prepare to be left on the edge
of your seat waiting for this indie thriller
to scare its way into theaters this summer.
It
If you're scared of clowns, the second trailer
for Stephen King's It is definitely not for
you.
The terror ramps up quickly with a tiny, horrifying
glimpse of Pennywise the clown.
Bill Skarsgård plays Pennywise, and he's
scaring an impressive cast of experienced
child actors, including St. Vincent's Jaeden
Lieberher and Stranger Things' Finn Wolfhard.
As the trailer shows, It isn't short on suspense
or all-out scares, and seems like a safe bet
to be the horror hit of the fall when it hits
theaters on September 8.
Woodshock
Another potential hit from the studio behind
Get Out, Woodshock stars Kirsten Dunst as
a woman who tries a drug that triggers hallucinations.
The trailer uses haunting music to show the
inner workings of Dunst's character, who appears
to be hiding a dark secret.
This trippy clip opens on a typically dramatic
note but quickly moves into the insane, getting
stranger as it goes on.
Get ready for a trip on September 15.
Blade Runner 2049
If you've been nervous about the upcoming
Blade Runner sequel, this trailer should calm
your fears.
The trailer offers a glimpse of a world entrenched
in the culture of the first film, and the
results are so gorgeous and action-packed
that it's impossible to look away.
Even more impressive: it does all this without
giving away too much of the movie's plot.
So feast your eyes, and don't worry about
the spoilers.
Chances are we'll get quite a few surprises
when the film finally arrives on October 6.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!